en este vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es
empezar con la expresión exponencial que
está en una forma bastante sencilla para
que después la transformemos en una
expresión que tenga una forma más
peliaguda así que pues manos a la obra
qué te parece si te muestro en primer
lugar la expresión inicial que vamos a
querer transformar y después criticamos
sobre por qué en realidad quiero hacer
todo esto así que vamos a empezar con lo
siguiente con 1 sobre 32 sobre 32 que
multiplica a 2 elevado a la potencia de
lo cual date cuenta es una expresión
bastante sencilla pero imagínate que
ahora la queremos transformar en una
expresión que se vea de la siguiente
forma
no voy a poner justo por acá am que
multiplica
avn este elevado a la potencia de sobre
10 ya esto le voy a quitar 1
la cual ya se ve un poco terrorífica así
que seguramente lo primer hito que vas a
decir es porque tomar una expresión tan
sencilla y bien portada como esta y
transformarla en una expresión tan loca
y la respuesta es que cuando empiezas a
estudiar matemáticas más avanzadas y
empiezas a tomar cursos de física y
química te vas a topar con resultados
como este y al ver la respuesta en el
libro o la respuesta que te da el
profesor te toparás con el resultado
visto de esta manera y en ese momento te
podrías preguntar cómo podemos pasar de
esta expresión inicial a esta expresión
de la derecha de hecho algunas veces
cuando transformas algo como esto bueno
claro cuando no está escrito de una
forma arbitraria pero lo que voy es que
algunas veces cuando transformas una
expresión que se ve un poco espeluznante
puede darte una intuición del proceso
subrayado de la expresión que estás
intentando describir así que manos a la
obra vamos a trabajar con esta expresión
sencilla y seguro en la marcha saldrán
las leyes de los exponentes así que
veamos si puedes
esto de esta forma
bueno asumiendo que ya lo intentaste
vamos a trabajarlo juntos así que lo
primero que se me ocurre que podemos
hacer es bueno fíjate en staten lo que
voy a intentar es transformar esta tema
en algo que tenga que ver con te sobre
10 y para eso lo que se me ocurre que
podemos hacer es estate multiplicarla y
dividirla por 10 para que no se afecte
su valor así que si a ésta templa
multiplicó por 10 y lo divido entre 10
bueno pues date cuenta que no acepto el
valor pero ahora lo podemos escribir de
la siguiente manera primero tengo este 1
sobre 32 un 32 se aboque lo voy a poner
justo por aquí un 32 ya que a su vez
está multiplicando a 2 elevado y ahora
date cuenta de lo siguiente lo que voy a
hacer es atrapar con este color a esta t
es de 10 a esta división de tema entre
10 así que lo voy a poner por aquí 2
elevado a la t sobre 10 y bueno después
habrá que multiplicarlo por este 10 así
que vamos a multiplicar por diez cuando
multiplicó y dividido por diez
date cuenta que regresamos a donde
empezamos sin embargo aquí puedo
utilizar una de las leyes de los
exponentes y bueno de hecho sería mucho
más fácil si lo viéramos de la siguiente
manera déjame borrar todo esto lo voy a
escribir como 2 que está elevado a la
potencia 10 y esto a su vez está
multiplicando a t entre 10 a entre 10 y
lo estoy poniendo de esta forma porque
estoy seguro que en este momento hay una
ley de los exponentes que te salta a la
vista recuerda que existe una ley que
dice que si tenemos a amd elevado a la
potencia vez y esto a su vez está
elevado a la potencia cm
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme y ha
elevado a la forcé o dicho de otra
manera si tenemos a ha elevado al ave
por ser es lo mismo que escribir a ha
elevado a la vez y esto a su vez elevado
a la potencia c así que esta propiedad
vamos a aplicarla justo por aquí por lo
tanto de esta parte de aquí de esta
parte que tenemos aquí voy a obtener lo
siguiente déjame ponerlo con este color
lo que voy a obtener es a 2 a 2 que está
elevado a la potencia 10 y esto a su vez
lo voy a llevar a la potencia bueno te
sobre 10 t sobre 10
fíjate que lo único que estoy haciendo
es aplicando esta propiedad de los
exponentes una vez más fíjate que 2
elevado a la 10 y esto a su vez elevado
a la t entre 10 es lo mismo que 2
elevado a la 10 por t entre 10 y bueno
no olvidemos este 1 entre 32 así que lo
voy a poner justo por aquí aquí tengo 1
30 y 12 ago un 32 y hago y estoy muy
tentado escribir justo ahorita que esto
es lo mismo que 2 elevado a la menos 5
pero todavía voy a esperar un poco por
ahora lo que quiero hacer es elevar
todos a la décima potencia entonces voy
a poner uno sobre 32 o keith ya esto lo
voy a multiplicar por y en este caso
tengo 2 elevado a la 10 lo cual sabemos
que es 1024 1024 esto elevado a la
potencia t
sobre 10 y bueno quiero que te des
cuenta que ya estamos muy cerca de
llegar a justo esto que tenemos aquí si
te das cuenta aquí tenemos a am aquí
tenemos a pm elevado a la t entre 10 y
nos falta solamente un -1 y para llegar
a esto vamos a aplicar la misma idea que
aplicamos acá arriba lo que voy a hacer
es tomarme la suma de 1 y menos 1 para
no afectar este exponente por lo tanto
voy a restar primero menos 1 y a sumar 1
y si te das cuenta no estoy afectando el
exponente y esto es importantísimo
fíjate que si sumamos 1 y restamos 1
no estamos afectando el exponente de
igual manera que arriba si multiplicamos
por 10 y dividimos por 10
no estamos afectando al exponente y
bueno una vez que tenemos esto como
podemos abrirlo pues lo que quiero que
veas es lo siguiente si te das cuenta
aquí tengo t entre 10 menos 1 esta parte
de aquí es justo lo que yo quería así
que necesitamos quitar este + 1 y para
quitar este más 1
otra ley de los exponentes la cual me
dice que si tengo a ha elevado a la
potencia b ya esto lo multiplicó por ha
elevado la potencia cm bueno lo que
vamos a obtener es la misma base pero en
este caso los exponentes se suman b más
dicho de otra manera si tengo una base
elevada a una potencia y está
multiplicado por la misma base elevado a
otra potencia entonces nos quedamos con
la misma base y sumamos las potencias en
este caso tenemos aquí un +1 así que
podemos verlo de la otra manera si tengo
a amd elevado a la vez más cm es lo
mismo que ha elevado a la vez por ha
elevado a la cem así que apliquemos lo
justo aquí si te das cuenta todo esto
que tengo aquí todo esto que tengo aquí
lo voy a poner de la siguiente manera
primero me va a quedar 1024 1024 esto
elevado a la potencia de entre 10 esto
elevado a la potencia de entre 10 menos
uno que es justo lo que quería y después
tengo que fijarme en esta otra potencia
la cual la voy a escribir como recuerda
esta propiedad de los exponentes me
dicen que habrá que multiplicar a esto
con la misma base
el 24 elevado a la otra potencia elevado
a la potencia 1 este 1 salió de aquí y
bueno no olvidemos al 1 es entre 30 y 21
entre 32 multiplicando y si te das
cuenta ya estamos muy pero muy cerca de
nuestro resultado final va a llegar a
nuestro resultado final lo que voy a
hacer es lo siguiente déjenme poner aquí
un signo de igual y bueno este 1024 lo
voy a pasar al principio multiplicando a
este un 30 y 20 y me va a quedar lo
siguiente voy a obtener a 1024 y bueno
1024 elevado a la potencia 1 es lo mismo
que 1024 1024 aquí le voy a poner una
coma y bueno si quieres le puedes
agregar todas las comas que sean
necesarias ésta y ésta y esté 1024
lo voy a dividir entre 32 y este 32 lo
voy a poner con su color rojo
a esto lo voy a dividir entre 32 y bueno
después tengo toda esta expresión de
aquí que es 1024 1024 elevado a la
potencia de entre 10 y a esto le voy a
quitar 1
y ya estamos cerquita del resultado
habrá que simplificar un poco esto así
que para eso voy a bajar esta pantalla
para que lleguemos al resultado y bueno
para simplificar esto date cuenta que
1024 bueno esto sabemos que es 2 elevado
a la décima potencia salió justo de aquí
así que lo voy a poner como 2 elevado a
la décima potencia 2 elevado a la décima
potencia mientras que 32 bueno eso
sabemos que es exactamente lo mismo que
2 elevado a la quinta potencia 2 elevado
a la quinta potencia y ahora para
reducir estos dos voy a utilizar otra
ley de los exponentes otra ley de los
exponentes que me dice lo siguiente que
si tengo a ha elevado a la vez y esto a
su vez dividido entre ha elevado al ac
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
ha elevado a la b menos cm así que en
este caso voy a obtener 2 elevado a las
10 entre 2 elevado a la 5 es lo mismo
que dos elevado a las diez menos 5
es 2 elevado a 5 así que lo voy a poner
justo por aquí de todo esto que tenemos
aquí de todo esto que tenemos aquí lo
puedo reducir de la siguiente manera con
este color y déjame bajar un poco más
esta pantalla con este color me va a
quedar que esto va a ser igual a 2
elevado a la quinta potencia lo cual
bueno sabemos que es 32 32 que
multiplican que multiplica a 1024 déjame
ponerlo con su respectivo color a 1024
esto elevado a la potencia de sobre 10
menos 1 y está de lujo porque es justo
lo que queríamos así que una vez más
quiero decirte que normalmente lo que
queremos es hacer las cosas lo más
simple que se pueda yo en lo personal
intento cuidar mucho ese aspecto porque
parece una buena filosofía de vida pero
este es el caso contrario el típico caso
en donde
tenemos que trabajar para hacer las
cosas más peliagudas para llegar a este
resultado si te das cuenta empezamos con
1 sobre 32 que multiplica a 2 elevado
late que por cierto cabe decir que
existe una forma de escribir justo esto
de una manera un poco más sencilla y
bueno todo el vídeo consistió en jugar
con esa expresión para transformarlo en
esta otra expresión que tenemos justo
aquí la cual bueno es un poco más loca
pero muy importante es que sepamos
hacerlo imagínate un escenario en que
una persona obtenga un resultado
parecido al del principio y que tú
obtengas justo este escenario parecido
al está el final sería muy importante
que se dieran cuenta de que llegaron al
mismo resultado que son dos formas
distintas de escribir la misma expresión
exponencial